[موسيقى]
تقع سيلينا تورتا في رومانيا على بعد 400 قدم تحت
سطح المدينة ، وهي مدينة
ملاهي تحت الأرض داخل أحد
أقدم مناجم الملح في العالم
[موسيقى]
يُعتقد أن سيلينا تورتا
عمرها 2000 عام تقريبًا خلال فترة عملها كملح
يُقدر أنه تم استخراج أكثر من 3 مليارات
طن من الملح من
الجدران قبل توقف التعدين في عام 1932 ، كان لهذا
المركز تحت الأرض استخدامات مختلفة
في الماضي من مركز تخزين الجبن إلى
ملجأ من القنابل في الحرب العالمية الثانية ، ولكن
ربما يكون استخدامه حاليًا هو  الأكثر تميزًا
في أوائل التسعينيات من القرن الماضي ، تم تحويل سيلينا تورتا
بعناية إلى منتزه ترفيهي تحت الأرض
ومتحف ، تشتمل هذه الحديقة النشطة
على مدرج يضم 180 مقعدًا
وبحيرة تحت الأرض مع مجداف
وقوارب صفية وملعب غولف صغير وطاولات بينج بونج
وبالطبع عجلة فيريس أكثر من 2
مليون شخص  قاموا بزيارته منذ
افتتاحه ، سيجعلك التأثير المذهل
للمكان تشعر وكأنك تركت
الواقع في أرض العجائب الجوفية
[موسيقى]